so man has a very very long history as
long as i can remember
i've been eating salmon during summer
time
it's usually salt the cold and it's a
really great noodle
so may something that i feel like a lot
of non-japanese people wouldn't
recognize but this is staple dish in
japan during the summer time i can't
even remember how many times i ate so
many for my lunch
it's very affordable and everyone can
make a home
this is something you won't usually see
at restaurants it's something you will
see in home cooking
it's super easy and it only takes two to
three minutes to boil my mom makes a lot
during summer time it's very refreshing
it's a very quick meal to fix so i think
it's a noodle for busy people some is
very thin and it's also dried so it has
a good shelf life
usually it's soft it's meant to you so
simple so man it's just meant to you
with scallion for this tasty japan video
they made four different varieties of
dipping sauce the most fun memory about
salmon that i have again it's during
summer camp in japan we make a slide
made out of bamboo so you cut bamboo in
half and remove all the segments so you
are making giant long slide
then you pour water and slide some along
with it
and you're gonna catch the salmon with
your chopsticks
i'm really good at picking so many
noodles
i don't know so it's a little bit tricky
because some is sliding in front of you
so you have to catch it very quickly but
i was very good at it also during the
summer camp we made a dipping cup and
bamboo chopsticks
that style of salmon is called nagashi
salman
it's just like a very fun activity you
can make slide and playing with noodles
i think you can also find those kind of
restaurant in japan it's really cool i
wanted to recreate that experience here
with hitomi from nifty
who is my work wife
we've been talking about for years but
we haven't executed it we should really
do it and make a video out of it
for this recipe one of the ingredients
is umeboshi which is like japanese
pickled plum
it's super sour but it's very addictive
for me when i think about umeboshi it's
like when you look at lemon and you
salivate or your mouth feels a little
strange
we use it for rice balls and noodles
especially with cold noodles i think it
gives a nice kick to the noodle dish
also grated radish and umeboshi is a
golden combination it's like pork and
kimchi and peanut butter and jelly
umeboshi and grated radish is a great
flavor combination that has been used
for a very long time
[Music]
have you had something before if you
have let me know if you haven't go try
it
make a home and tell me what you think
[Music]
you